I want them to talk about how we can
prevent revolution by planting sweet
potato sweet potatoes as one of the
other cards that we teach justify mass
to planting their gardens now these are
the sweet potatoes with ran statute so
that when we plant the tubes we can have
these tubes having the sweet potatoes
that we hit during them grid fast even
at tea time at lunch and even at supper
the first thing that we do we just we
dig the terraces you can see these are
the trusses about that so are continuing
these terraces then we plant these sweet
potatoes at there you can see the other
top so that when the sweet potatoes have
their sweets then just and inside and
when we plant the sweet potatoes we
plant right this way you can see how I
do plant them one on this end the other
one on the other side they will do the
conservation funny you can see how we
plant them when we plant the other signs
that are not designed still turns even
their trees
I have even they have a kind of cheese
in my garden this is how we plant them
you can see it haha one on the other
side so that the time of covering these
ones this wire on the side they cover
designed and those who that one on the
other side the kaabah down those trusses
so when the rain comes they are the stop
of the rains the rain to move the the
swamp so that the smoke and not Ruth its
fertility so they these terraces they
are the one that there are
still they're here you can see the
hubba-hubbas back that up to in nineteen
Cuarenta in my candle can see have front
and haha these ones today just trying to
make it today to the way that these they
are so that I can feed my family through
this one still I can't have the bins to
fill the cut row and you know these fans
they have a lot of protein in the cut
row still I can tell they're sweet
potatoes that I would move from there
from this belt and my children can take
it as a food to attend certain to get
some him come and I think that is the
way we are mitigating to that it is
during now so this is my Cantor and I'm
still continuing to think how I can
change though we are too high can change
from the way we used to move out and
stay at home and keeping myself busy
doing something so that I won't get a
stretch so that our joy the place that
the ham and hand something from my stay
at home thank you